نواصل يعني استعراض تطورات المشهد
الاوكراني وهذه المره براي وتحليل من
بيروت مع العميد الياس حنا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
المشهد وكانه اشتعل اليوم يعني
جبهات متعدده ونطاق واسع للعمليات في
مناطق مختلفه من الطرفين كيف تقرا هذا
المشهد خاصا بعد تطور الاخير امس
عبد الصمد عندما
نلاحظ المؤشرات التكتيكيه على الارض والتي
تبدا من بريانسك الى كريمينا
وبالتالي
ومخموت حتى خرسان انما هذا امر يدل على ان
هناك شيء يحضر اذا ما اضفنا هذا الامر الى
التصريحات التي تبدا منسكي والى وزير
الدفاع الى رئيس الاركان الى قياده الجيش
وكان هناك شيء يحضر والكل ينتظر هذا
الهجوم اليوم نتحدث عن على سبيل المثال
عندما تقصف اومان وهي منطقه جنوب شمال
شمال مايكوليب او شمال 300 كم عن خرسون
انما هي العمق يعني من ينظر الى مدينه
عمان انها نقطه تحول اساسيه او نقرا
محوريه
لوجستيه تبدا من لفيف الى هذه المنطقه
اليوم عندما تقصف القوات الاوكرانيه ايضا
النفط وتستهدف بعض القطارات ببرياس انما
هي تستهدف اللوجستيه الاساسيه وكاننا
اليوم في مرحله الاعداد للهجوم عبر ضرب
اللوجستيه من الفريقين بالاضافه الى ما
يجري في مخموت عبد الصمد لكن الكلام اللي
يقول بانه لا خطط لبوتين الان لالقاء كلمه
او عقد اجتماع لمجلس الامن القومي ولا
تغيير وهذا ما اريد ان اشير اليه الى
تغيير في العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا ما
الذي يمكن ان نفهمه نحن من هذا التصريح
للكريم
عندما تم الحديث امبارح البارحه عن موضوع
استهداف الكرملين
ذهبت التحليلات الى القول تغيير اسم
العمليه من عمليه عسكريه خاصه الى اعلان
حرب وذهب بعض التحليلات الى استدعاء مزيد
من القوات وشن هجوم شامل وذابت بعض
التحليلات ايضا الى استهداف القيادات
الرسميه تبدا من الرئيسكي والى القيادات
العسكريه انما اليوم نحن في مرحله اعاده
التقييم لهذه المرحله ولكن دون شك عبد
الصمد ما حصل البارحه في الكلام والخطاب
المباشر والمعد مسبقا قد يكون يمكن القول
استهداف
الحكومه في اوكرانيا وكانه اليوم نذهب الى
مرحله تغيير الخطاب او مرحله
تاجيل العمليه العسكريه اذا صح التعبير او
تغيير الخطاب وحتى
الحرب الاعلاميه بين الفريقين والذهاب الى
الاتهام حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
باعداد ما حصل في الكلام
الغرب ككل بدعم اوكرانيا على انها تنفذ
عمليات ارهابيه داخل روسيا ومنها الكريم
مؤخرا شكرا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري واستراتيجي من بيروت